lyncher sur les réseaux après d'avoir
été trop virulent avec sa prétendante tu
as un texte explique dans tpm p il a
fait la connaissance de d'aguilat ils
ont eu trois mois de relation virtuelle
entre dhabi là et tu anh tuân y avait
des sentiments pour dalila avant de la
rencontrer
moi je l'aimais bien ouais pareil
toujours pas la première fois qu'on
s'est appelée on à rester 10 heures en
communication
10 heures en communication
avec au bout de deux heures cinquante
neuf le téléphone est coupé non ouais
j'avais pas battu val apprend des trucs
ouais
je les reprends des trucs en téléphonie
stade 2 et téléphonie la meet your
browser ça va donc à vif et c'était
vraiment où il y avait c'était un beau
filet ou pote quoi un pote bon allez bon
rien mais tu avais quand même envie de
faire une un truc avec quelques mois oui
à la base oui à la base oui avec apprêt
aujourd'hui et qui sont dépassés qu'est
ce qui s'est passé s'est passée ta vu
italien ben comme jésus comme en une
planche durant semaine du goût
sur place je sais pas tu vas n'est là
pour s'expliquer donc tu vois de quoi
que tu n'as pas accroché physiquement
avec dalila le fait qu'on sait jamais
appelé en face time et serait pour
garder ne vous êtes jamais appelé en
suspens voilà suspens et fait alors
[Rires]
garder le suspense a alors dany leila ce
soir vous allez vous expliquer or nous
demande d'applaudir dalila qui est avec
elle
[Applaudissements]
alors j'étais si fière sur m6 si vous
n'avez pas de suivi l'émission s'appelle
et si on se rencontre et j'explique le
principe aux téléspectateurs qu'ils nous
rejoignent à 20h44 en direct c'est très
simple des personnes se parlent
virtuellement sur les réseaux pendant
des semaines des semaines et même des
mois puisque vous vous êtes paris
pendant trois mois trois mois de
relation virtuelle trois mois de
relation on sent que l'amour va
peut-être vous réunir derrière le
smartphone derrière ce que vous voulez
derrière un écran l'amour est peut-être
grandissant jalila
est ce que toi quand tu as vu tuân
il était conforme à ce que tu
t'attendais oui donc tu étais tu
n'achètes eu la bien aimée oui j'ai bien
aimé donc toi tu étais prête à faire à
avoir une relation avec le tchad ben oui
comme on en avait parlé au téléphone on
s'est dit qu'on s'entendait super bien
on restait des heures au téléphone
deezer il nous a dit tu sais qu'au bout
de deux heures 50
c'est vrai que c'est ce que les
habituels et est donc et donc wayne est
donc là tu t'es dit toi tu as envie de
faire quoi une histoire une vraie
histoire d'amour avec woods devait se
construire avec moi à bâtir tout bildt 2
de bâtir tübitak béni oui oui d'accord
d'avoir à voir il faut vivre avec la
personne n'avait encore mais déjà ouais
c'est à dire vous vouliez faire une idée
le dinh il a 42 ans avancer l'histoire
commencé un homme voilà c'est ça et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est bien le
drame c'est à dire
en fait il a m'a carrément fait de
l'umih nation en public quoi en plus je
te le dis et je loue elle aboie
mais même si j'étais marche en fait dans
le volant mais je savais pas non
seulement sur ça c'est pas un mais deux
en plus c'est pas le cas je te lire
voilà je te dis donc tu n'as pas ton
angoissé pas parce que tu es magnifique
voilà je te le dis qu'est ce qui s'est
passé quoi tu anh a été pas tu as ta pas
plus dalila quand tu l'as vu
c'est à dire c'est pas surtout quand je
dis on n'avait que des photos ainsi de
suite a montré des photos ainsi de suite
après contre le virtuel et le réel c'est
pas tout ça quoi
envoyer des photos
filtré ok mais un jour je t'ai dis c'est
pas moi
j'assume je mets des filtres tiens je
vais t'envoyer une vidéo je suis juste
maquillée de trois secondes ou je te
fais un bisou comme ça c'est ça la vidéo
oui et après des photos maquillé mais
sans filtre pourquoi tu es venu de quoi
pour eux je suis venu oui pour péter
wiels bon sympathisé au talus haut et
donc c'est pas mon visage c'est mon
corps non il n'ya pas que le sort c'est
tout l'ensemble c'est lanta jamais vu
mon corps est à vue et tu met il pas
mettre encore si je les ai vus quand tu
es parti sur le plateau est ouvert la
porte j'ai vu là ton corps et alain
petit monde quitte à poser problème
c'est tout l'ensemble je te dis sinon
moi je suis très physique à ce que ça
donne le droit de danger aucun droit
comme j'en dis excuse moi si j'étais
vexé ou pas mais comme j'ai dit d'avoir
des opinions et à voir les goûts et les
couleurs s'excuse pas oui mais quand on
est un homme intelligent et qu'on veut
qu'on ne veut pas par exemple moi je
suis pas parfaite si un homme ne lui
plaît pas il a qu'à dire
respectueusement oui bah ça va pas le
faire il n'y a pas d'étincelle n'ya pas
s'il n'y a pas ça blablabla on est un
petit peu de chantilly mais droite a
carrément apte à tirer
qu'un malade ça se fait pas ça se fait
pas non mais tu te rends compte un peu
moi tu as de la chance je suis forte
ouais mais une autre nana là tu peux la
détruire en deux convois je dis pas le
contraire mais comme je te dis c'est
après moi comme jouer c'est que ouais
comme si j'ai fait un peu exprès pour
que toi tu me donnes alors on a on a le
vague ou dalida parce que tout le monde
se demande voilà voilà que vous avez
vous pourriez donc voilà chante la voile
amd voilà voilà enfin cesser les tweets
on met pas voir les photos s'il vous
plaît merci nordine c'est pas la peine
de m'envoyer que tu as les photos si tu
mets pas les photos merci donc voilà
dalia il faut tous ses téléphones donc
d'avant envoyé tuân
non ça c'est sûr mon astakhov autres
stades accord très bien voilà balibar
voit la vallée en fait je le dis en
privé quand un gars on s'intéresse
jeudi mais t'es trop belle sur tes
photos je vis ouvertement ses des
filtres bienvenue en 2022 16 en général
voilà ouais mais donc toi voilà
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que tu aurais à
dire as-tu and back texte un gros bâtard
orienté et en vérité le comprend et
encore ce que je peux rachetant terrible
oui ce que je peux rajouter c'est que
après ça oui monsieur je sais pas si
vous avez entendu la dernière fois que
julia qu'elle est venue sur votre
plateau elle a dit on a un gros poids de
sa rivale bien que tu parles de julia
leigh alors allez juste à côté julie bon
on l'a fait venir si tu veux c'est qu'il
julien et pourquoi tu la parole tu as
peur de quelque chose dont j'ai peur
c'est quoi cette histoire de gros sous
toit de sa non mais a vu qu'on se croise
et où ils ont fait un gros poids de sap
ça y'a pas de soucis oui que je sois pas
invitée je m'en fous mais total ouais
j'ai pas été invité mais je sais
pourquoi parce que j'ai reçu des screen
est en fait ils m'ont fait du body
shaming ans en bois du body shining et
son prix importent moins cher
ils ont pris une photo demande instagram
où j'avais ma mi-mars au cdh robes
rouges ouais dans l'hôtel son filtre
après avoir mangé une grosse pizza
quatre fromages d'accord c'était pas le
vrai choc
c'était d'un dans la coque du coup et où
ils ont commencé à dire ce qu'ils ont
dit 17 des collègues qui ont dit sur
instagram nous ont demandé cette
enceinte même c'est un gars prêt qu'a
dit le prochain qui m'a dit que si je
suis enceinte ou que j'ai mangé une
pizza il a fermé en mai montrent les
photos
de ce que vous faites alors là vous vous
niez une femme dans celle là des années
des photos réelles et la sublime qu'elle
soit vue vous regardez les six mêmes
larmes et la manière dont vous vous
comportez monsieur c'est
alors n'a rien vous excuser franchement
alors attendez vous savez qu'à d'où ils
venaient julia je suis là c'est la jeune
fille qui était voilà qui peut aussi
s'expliquer on va voir là une
explication triptyque la peur pour son
lynchage mais par contre elle a fait
derrière sur moi à oui c'est ça il faut
que je garde ses sept jeux de suite
alors il y avait été remis à tous est
vraiment d hypocrite non non c'est toi
qu'est ce que tu as envoyé ce matin sur
facebook et tous à escalans lui demande
ce qu'elle a envoyé à l'est on veut bien
été envoyée
facebook regarde on saute on saute et
page et nous on peut même pas tant ont
tous regardé sur ton truc parce qu'à
chaque fois tu caches tout regard c'est
quoi qu'est ce qui s'est passé ces
partitions à
copenhague voilà c'est fini non non
c'est bon tu veux te venger on va
rigoler à ces
[Musique]
jeunes alors d'habitude je ne suis pas
là pour ça alors oui c'est quoi [ __ ]
tu échoues il ya bien quelqu'un qui vous
appelle un cecelia levée de la vieille
ville et au monde depuis j'ai rien
compris voilà donc à oui d'accord il
sait quoi tout ça en fait gérés c'est
elle qui a mis ça sur le fond ça je veux
dire vous avez dit - sur ma story vous
voulez des preuves je vais mettre ça les
screen de whatsapp en toi ils sont en
train de se moquer d'elle et aux
problèmes réels et mis sa maison parce
qu'il est bête qui pensent que non mais
elle assume personnellement je savais
très
relâchée
dans la sauce regorge de ressources
alors s'il vous plaît guillon moi je le
sais évidemment c'est très violent et
très frontal de se moquer du physique
comme ça mais moi je vous soupçonne un
peu de le faire pour faire parler de
vous pour le buzz et cette émission
c'est dommage parce qu'elle le concept
idée géniale au début il y avait des
gens très sincère bon alors on l'a
confirmé quelqu'un de la production de
la confirmer plus l'audience monde plus
il ya des gens qui veulent faire de la
télé qui sont pas sincères est-ce que ce
n'était pas calculé tout ça fait deux
mandats de l'état se calculer ou pas on
n'est pas des acteurs à la base ce qu'il
est et ce qu'il voit la base on s'est
dit on va surtout qu'il oublie de dire
c'est que ya eu pire mais que m6 sa part
voulu faire le montage à cause du csa
jeu m'a parlé le vrai montage si vous a
dit il ma part tu m'as parlé de cul
c'était presque de l'harcèlement sexuel
n'ont en rien supérieur soit humain tu
veux que je te dise comment il m'a dit
toi tu as bien de prendre des trucs dans
le cul jamais dix ans
marty une hernie parti qui aiment
prendre des trucs dans le
vrai que la ja la base compagnie alors
s'il vous plaît ça ne veut pas ça c'est
vraiment pas ils ont les images et si je
peux porter plainte je peux récupérer
les images c'est dans la merde mais bon
je crois que ça on voit bien que ce ne
sont pas des copies déjà au rendez vous
kabila vous saviez descendants financier
jamais vécu ça mais de toute ma vie je
vous jure mais c'est normal pas non plus
bien
[Rires]
n'est pas un truc
oui d'accord vous étiez est ce que m'a
même parlé de son ver solitaire
je sais qu'en tendance
c'est quoi si sur deux ne
sait pas comment se parler on parle de
toi c'est toi qui parlait de lui me suis
allé pareil tu parlais pas mais tu
parlais pareil c'est normal ouais ben
voilà c'est ça
du premier rencard de lui parler comme
ça si on sait pas parler comme ça qu'on
s'en faut qu'elle arrête de mentir on
pas pour dix ans une femme comme ça pour
voir comment 10h du chiffon faut arrêter
travail seront alors oui on parle de
chiffon
et après tu veux tu veux me donner la
clé tu veux qu'elle va prévoir ajouté
pas en laye a de quoi franchement il ya
de quoi rajouter
je te dis merci oui alors sur ps3 avant
géraldine guilbon qui est d'accord et
que tu as menée par ailleurs d'accord
c'est peut-être voilà vous aggravez
votre cas quand on mène on arrête tout
mais moi effectivement vous êtes bruce
vous êtes un pays respectueux vous êtes
très cash mais en même temps arrêtons
aussi de jouer les hypocrites même si
c'est très très violents ce que vous
avez à subir les hommes jugent les
femmes violemment et les femmes jugent
les hommes violemment ça veut dire que
vous croyez vous belle bande
d'hypocrites ici que vous quand vous
allez en train de vous est empreint de
chine et une à nawa vous allez pas
regarder son cul vous n'allez pas faire
neowin on le
sait pas
un premier rendez vous mais pas tous en
merlot denis les mecs vont dire on
semble aller comme celle-là est comme ça
et de la même manière si par exemple
vous vous auriez dit maintenant mädchen
par exemple à hilla du bide où il a un
peu de bedaine et tout ça alors là on
n'aurait pas trouvé que c'est scandaleux
mais aussi c'est parce que c'est un
homme qui s'adresse à une femme et là on
crie au scandale vous avez trouvé
extrêmement vulgaire et déplacer donc
j'aime pas ça mais arrêtons de jouer les
hypocrites évidemment qu'à des critères
évidemment conduit évidemment qu'il ya
des gens qui vous plaisent et qui vous
plaisent pas voilà sauf que quand on se
voit pas on sait pas si on se plaît
voilà quand on voit on sait déjà mal
géré élection ne fait pas rêver au
premier rendez vous on va te faire rêver
comme à au moins il aima hypocrite on
l'a mal à boire vaillant et donc alors
dit des horreurs
tu piges à la base est là bas pardon à
la base déjà on s'était dit quoi tu
m'avais dit si je passe à la télé avec
toi tu me next pas devant la france
entière d'accord mais non tu m'as dit
sérieux au moins non c ou b chaud là bas
j'en ai ou pas tu as le droit lui
locklear à la loi dire ça voilà ça veut
que moi-même peillon s'écouler pas le
même temps mais ce qui me plaisait pas
et ben j'aurais dit banques continuent à
passer un bon moment dans le chai à toi
moi alors vous avez vous de devoir son
ver solitaire
non on s'est dit ah là bas soit une
cession s'est dit à un moment m'a dit
toi tu grossis pata ver solitaire en
rigolant je dis pas ce qu'il veut j'ai
dit tu grossis pourquoi fais du sport tu
m'a dit j'ai pas besoin
voilà j'ai aperçu des habitudes le passo
faire c'est un jeune et si tu veux je te
le pass pour tout le monde ici même chez
adacore voilà maintenant que
là tu veux parler comme ça avec
mathieu en deux ans il n'y a pas d'âge
pour parler comme ça va bien sûr nation
ça alors je fais un brelan il accepte le
problème était
très nerveux matches où tu vas voir un
avocat à côté de toi dont j'ai quatre
enfants alors
quatre enfants voilà je suis insulte
pour toi vous êtes très joli et c'est
pas le souci il est effectivement goujat
un peu goujat maintenant il a passé 10
heures avec quelqu'un il s'est attaché à
quelqu'un il a essayé de connaître
quelqu'un qui a la balle ce pardon si on
revient vraiment à la base celui des
deux qui a triché et vous non mais j'ai
vu des deux qui a menti sidiki lycée
vous non mais c'est pas parce que vous
dites vous
on traite dans une photo en disant je te
préviens j'ai un fils donc lui forcément
bas le jour où vous a rencontré il est
passif 10 heures au téléphone il a cru
que c'était une jolie fille on est tous
pareils
il est déçu alors il a été déçu de
manière un peu violente parce
qu'effectivement il a passé 10 heures au
téléphone impression revient totalement
la base a été honoré deux jolies mais la
jeune fille qui a triché au départ c'est
vous c'est pas nouveau mais messieurs
laissez la réponse décennale il à
répondre à matthieu delormeau dalila
après vous prendrez la défonce jambe
droite en fait c'est comme s'ils étaient
assez aldo avec le cadeau ultime déjà
quand tu as dis ouais je m'attendais à
une voiture de luxe
tu me compare à une voiture toi je
compare sa loge il commande une bmw
toujours soin de twingo c'est pareil
tu peux dire je dis ça je vais pas dire
ça comme ça je parle comme ça je
conçois de la rend pas compte de la
violence que tu dis mais comme il ya une
différence entre le penser le dire à la
personne et le dire à la personne devant
un million de personnes et là on en
rigole un million
il ya des gens qui sont traumatisés par
ça et souvent c'est pas du tout contre
vous mais souvent les gens qui formule
des attaques gratuites et frontale sur
le physique d'un leader mais tu t'es vu
toi les amène à miami la raison
les gens pour les maldives et vu toi
c'est quoi emmagasiner du monde qu'est
ce qu'il peut c'est pas contre vous et
les gens je te rassure
[Applaudissements]
battu à nantes nantes a pas eu la parole
non tu te calmes que tu veux dire moi
oui je me tais tu es beau tu verras que
tu veux dire tu étais tout des jt oui
passe quelque chose de qualité perdure
pourquoi t'es perdure parce qu'encore
une fois forcément m6 et c'est normal
montrent les missions donc on voit la
fin la fin d'une relation qui en fait à
plusieurs heures de discussions ils se
sont connus fils parle de manière aussi
cru que on s'est ratés comme ça c'est
qu'il en est le site et avant il ya une
intimité alors c'était justement pour
puisse avoir des complexes mais rendez
vous désole le coin droit de vous parce
que quand il m'a dit ah je te faire un
poil en eau et tous ses pouvoirs mais
pas le punch parler comme ça d'aller
l'homme dont l'âge est une arme sur lui
alors jean-luc on parle pas comme ça
c'est toi qui me parlaient comme ils
ont déserté parce qu il pesé
physiquement tête et valberg au départ
tout aussi mais la voilà maintenant mais
c'est quoi tu l'avais rencontré
finalement il avait des gens sérieux je
suis intelligente paku paku that way et
j'aurais dit autre chose genre je
ressens rien on jurerait pas donné
l'accolade il est très beau [ __ ] à ce que
s'est passé tellement d'heures avant
vexé ou se dit [ __ ] mais c'est pas
la
faute de dalila parce que elle a péché
sur ces photos mais on n'a pas bien
écouté à lui a fait une vidéo de 3
secondes ou être sans maquillage
laventie tous les vidéos elle ment parce
que dans les vidéos il
ajouté
sur les vidéos à chaque fois qu'on passe
sur m6 fallait qu'on s'envoie des vidéos
à m6 sans filtre a ainsi de suite voilà
chaque fois je lui dis en voile moi je
l'envoie les miens avant que je passe à
la télévision et je dis on voit les
tiens non j'ai pas envie elle n'a jamais
envoyé voilà tu m'as dit là on fera la
surprise quand m6 m'ont dit mais moi ils
ont joué le jeu il m'a dit ils m'ont dit
c'est seulement le fait de francs pour
toi et délai d'un mois et monsieur simon
dit il mon dit à moins de 10 je veux
donner à clé à dajla ou pas j'ai dit il
m'a dit tu la next ou pas moi
franchement j'avais envie sauf que comme
tu dis j'avais pas envie tonique c'est
parce qu'on sait et on s'était juré tu
m'as dit sur la france entière tu aimes
tu m'as fait venir tu me n'existe pas et
moi je n'ai qu'une parole je suis
bouddhiste et cela n'était pas une
excuse mais je préfère que tout est neuf
c'est pour ça que c'est qu'il est chez
elle ce prêt pour tuer un extra
mais des coûts jamais l'essentiel
s'il vous plaît lavez souvient aussi
qu'il y avait eu ce problème oui qui
s'était fait fracasser sur les réseaux
sociaux il était venu nous voir et julia
et là ce soir pourquoi elle est là ce
soir ce que voulait ma compagne et tout
ça parce qu'elle adore à tous à
beauvais bah non c'est que cet appareil
on se voyait tous avec un matador et
usain bolt à paris avec d'anciens venue
à paris alors julien va venir lui à
venir sans peine juste gilabert
s'installer pendant que j'exposerai
répond mme dalila canalis parce qu'avec
son avocat match est nominé musique
l'avocat matthew est en train de s'en
sortir oui est prêt aux garçons de faire
ce qu'elle est honnête vous plaindre est
mai mais ce que vous avez fait monsieur
c je vais appeler comme ça on n'en
dégueulasse je veux te payer un tel vous
rendez pas compte de la violence ou la
maîtresse en tutu peuvent excéder
j'entends c'est quand tu en parles dans
les experts comme ça non physique j'ai
bien aimé paillage même pas un match
auquel est filtrée encore on ne parle
pas comme ça un être humain dit par
contre un peu de temps mais c'est comme
cela que jacky ickx et user de la
manière qu'il a parlé
à la barre
et mathieu on s'en fout là c'est bon je
vais y lit à julia cayla julia c'est bon
elle et de leurs mots merci à giulia qui
hélas du lien vous vous étiez sûr vous
avez fait des missions et sur les
réseaux si ça a été compliqué pour vous
parce que les gens disaient que les
photos n'étaient pas conformes à ce que
vous étiez en réalité est là aujourd'hui
dalida hier ça a été compliqué pour elle
est paraît-il que voilà giulia aussi
vous a également critiqué ce que vous
vouliez dire c'est pour ça que voulait
qu'elle vienne là ce soir j'ai pas dis
que c'est sur le passé moi j'étais juste
venu accompagné de yoann on est venu me
chercher en loges pour que je descende
rapidement maintenant s'il faut mettre
les choses au clair on peut mettre les
suisses eux car j'ai une question pour
dalila est ce que tu cherches vraiment
le buzz ou pas parce que tu ressors des
dossiers qui date d'il ya ce n'est qu'en
février une sanctionne de février en
plus les stories que tami qui ont été
pris sur instagram et ccd story que tu
as masqué à quasiment tous les
participants de l'émission et
heureusement que tu es perimount pas
parce que je il ya le numéro de
téléphone j'ai pas fais 90 à masquer
testory pour que les participants de
l'émission ne les voit pas et aux
pierres bas on allait voir alors on n'en
met d'accord c'est gentil devenir
devenir clash et de vente à la france a
expliqué les histoires qui sont
personnelles et qui on n'a absolument
rien à voir avec un glissement entre
gaulle met d'accord mais dans ce cas là
pourquoi t'es pas venu soit nous en
parler directement soit ne pas masquer
testory on simplement
le ton petit fan club qui est venu nous
insulter et que c'était un message privé
machin dans la sans connaître l'histoire
sans connaître la version que vous avez
fait les bouffons et vous donnons donc
pour être apte de niveau entre
guillemets tu fais la bouffonne devant
tous ces chambardements est-ce que moi
quand je t'ai vu dans la salle là bas
dans château est ce que je t'ai mal par
les photons et justement également
parler d'elle il a justement elle parle
et c'est le gars bien dans leur jeu dans
nos trente minutes j'étais même entendu
te plantes de challenge et écouté
pendant 30 minutes et tu vas aller en
temps quand j'attends d'abord interview
pour pierre jeune tim cahill est souple
et merci juste aujourd'hui dalida
mariez-vous sérieux est ce que vous
trouvez donc je peux pas est ce que tu
pourrais faire quelque chose avec thual
maintenant aujourd'hui mais je n'en ai
jamais la mer qui n'est jamais bon alors
lui même si je suis mais c'est le
dernier homme sur terre notre l'amène à
oui c'est vrai à jamais a dit manuel
walls en fait après gilles verdez
avec toi tu as créé par gilles verdez
chez toi c'est moi que toi tu as oui
c'est moi c'est sur ces notes avaient
soufflé où j'aurai pas que lâcher comme
ça quoi vraiment bah oui j'aurais pas
que lâcher comme ça c'était parce que et
les shows lincoln gratuit pour vous pour
vous les goûts les concerts discute pas
les jolies pascal ac maquillé mais la
barrière des riads à la télévision
[Applaudissements]
la tunisie qui n'en là là je n'ai réussi
alors là bas mais franchement quand je
vois par l'ex terrain je me dis qu'est
ce qu'ils se sont dit pendant des heures
et des heures ils se rencontrent ils se
connaissent pas du tout l'ennemi n'a ni
l'autre et en fait on peut penser à des
camps d'été d'allaiter en fait vous êtes
dans un buzz permanent d'être là pour
vous montrer tout ça n'a rien à voir ni
l'amour ni la ville ni l'envié pas
d'inventer mais non les malheurs avec
montrer et match là des gens
qui te poser chercher l'amour et tout ça
parce que tu es le boss à la base album
chercher l'amour vraiment et après du
petit copain cinquième déjà je sais pas
c'est quoi ce week-end parce que je suis
passé alors je
rigole normes alors non mais c'est vrai
question où les charrues l'amour
vraiment oui ben moi comme j ça fait des
enjeux célibataire je fais que de
l'intérim je me mets moi de poser une
question tu t'entends des super bien je
t'entends disent solidaires bien avec
dali franchement rien c'est important de
bien ce n'est quelques
mois dites moi je vois franchement très
joli qu'est-ce qui a fait que ça a pas
parce que rien même si je t'entends
hyper bien avec elle même si elle est un
petit peu en dessous des attentes
franchement il ya je l'adoré ci a déjà
l'essentiel je l'adorais mais quand je
les ai vus sama aux armes c'est à dire
j'avais pas c'est pas mon gusto ya des
façons plus je comprends courageux mais
ce que je veux et tu m'a descendu mais
rejetée descendu bon tu me vient pas là
car m6 1 ils ont pas ils ont leur pour
la prison ils ont tourné leur thé comme
les racines chez dégueulasse comment
dire jusque le changement chat sur le
dire sans avoir un will smith là pour
leur mettre une grosse barre d'un sacré
alors suivant là on a un mais constant
de smith merci daniel mots je pense que
c'est là que l'axé où ça fait que je te
dis elle même pas taper alors daniel
daniel moi je suis dégoûté et j'aimerais
savoir est-ce qu'il est également un
petit peu par téléphone ou alors est ce
qui est vraiment et parce que
j'ai pas de lampe ou tu me parlais le
bronze pour moi n'est pas faire de
compliments tu l'as dit ou pas je me dis
avec vous pendant des mois passés avec
ce téléphone n'ont parlé des fous mais
vraiment de tout et vous essayez de
vendre la mèche pour rigoler bien il
sait y faire et faisait rire maintenant
c'est vrai que fait rien y faire et
lorsque j'ai des bonnes blagues aussi
c'est maintenant des fois c'est bon mais
on parle et moi moi jadida où aller là
bas et je peux me permettre oui j'ai
l'impression que je vais faire mon
analyse de cette affaire j'ai quand même
l'impression que dalila a quand même un
petit cross pour tuân malgré tout elle
aime bien elle est triste parce que
aussi qu'elle se voyait bien avec lui
parce que j'ai l'impression que ça
collait bien ce que je ressens tu anh
toi je me demande si tata pas voulu
faire un coup d'éclat non voilà il que
tu regrettes aujourd'hui parce que dany
là c'est peut-être tp non non non en
jetant si elle était comme les filtres
et tout ça
mais je la voyais comme ça je la voyais
pas comme ça c'est
comme je dis ça veut dire jamais été
très divisé pour les autres mettaient
pas très physique pour toi apparemment
[Applaudissements]
je n'aime pas une personne qu'il faut
que je suis donc c'est un très mauvais
exemple pour les jeunes qui regardent
qui montraient intéressés à ce genre
d'émission parce que c'est rigolo c'est
à confirmer les jeunes qui regardent du
conciliateur le jeune homme il faut je
pense que
les plaintes shane kim avec ça comme il
a raison il y aura les hôtes abu
dhabi demande la permission de vendre
regardant les fesses d'une femme en fait
comme en tulle commune en mai s'est
passé et comment il est à la droite de
regarder la droite pense à produire
parce
que j'ai ce que vous avez vu des photos
de lui il a mais ils mettent des filtres
sur les photos à vous n'avez pas idée
alors il ya plein de gens qui disent que
les dix ya plein de gens qui disent que
vous êtes au koweit tout ça est fake est
ce que vous en pensez mais je n'arrive
pas à croire
leur et le soir où je rentre à l'hôtel
après quand j'ai vu votre quad
dégueulasse j'ai pleuré sur j'ai appelé
la fraude j'ai dit mais c'est quoi cette
merde en fait
appeler n'a même pas décroché quant à
dicter à refuser la créa si suite il m'a
même pas dit m'a dit je te parle pas te
rouvert après tournage il t'a même dit
aux gens tu as vu un julien barat
calotte est en plus c'est moi la
persécution chaque fois que sa vue à
bordeaux a laissé les messages ont bien
été sélectionnés pour ce serait tout le
temps moi je comprends pas si ce
complément vous le dis un truc non après
le dire à lui que veut dire voilà pour
moi l'idée tout ce que les meufs doivent
éviter faut éviter à tout prix les mecs
comme ça il parle de voiture il compare
des meufs à des voitures l'aï dit qu'il
a besoin de vos titres ailleurs parler
non pas moi je suis pas dans la réalité
est en fait et en fait ce
[Applaudissements]
que les filles doivent éviter c'est des
mecs comme lui en fait ils s'amusent ils
jouent il se prend pour un ouvrage un
mètre soixante
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
suffit pas de faire des coloriages sur
les robes en fait pas de mettre du gel
je n'ai pas de gel des gens tout à fait
blancs
mais pourquoi tu
t'arrêtes tu as des bracelets tout est
beau là c'est bien la raison c'est bon
comme beaucoup merci merci m'énerve moi
c'est que tu dis ça fait deux ans que
j'ai pas de meuf pour que des sports
j'ai pas vu jean avis a fait changer
de la verrerie parce que je suis vexé ne
peut pas parler comme ça des airs
courtois mr
[Applaudissements]
m
gérard philippe amagou
kayak tir à l'équipe et du violon et là
ça n'arrête jamais en tant que j'aurais
dis ce que tu as un intérêt à agir non
j'aime très longtemps je vous trouve
juste très hypocrite sait très bien ce
qu'il a dit il s'est excusé point touche
à chaque fois j'y arrive je voulais soir
à dire et dans son verre attention mitu
faut faire attention plus autoriser les
voir non pas les mecs se servent des
femmes attention les yeux la tension
émane des charges il est en train de me
dire que lui s'est drossée don quichotte
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
ces donjons donc des gens qui
voulaient bon dieu fera doucement sa
douce et du fait que je viens de me tue
at on a une famille non mais moi je vais
vous dire un peu mon parcours parce
qu'il sait pas tous mes histoires mais
dites vous quand je fait longtemps que
c'est quoi tes rapports mais c'est
le rapport à l'histoire de mon
côté des visiteurs mon histoire on va
pleurer tout de suite je sais que ma
femme depuis 12 ans ouais elle est
partie avec mon pote mon meilleur pote
que j'hébergeais chez moi nom herman
assat elle est partie avec lui elle m'a
fait qu'aucune chez moi non c'est pas de
ta faute c'est pas ton comportement je
crois que tu le mérites et des ja
[Applaudissements]
on va dire
que c'est pas tant que ça je veux pas
dire qu'il ait l'effet vie des gens
assez combatif pas je ne sais pas mais
c'est pas la peine qu'on créera d'accès
pour les combats comme tâche est ce que
tu anh tuân bakchich a tué oui c'est
peut-être pas gentil mais c'est pas une
raison pour ne pas me porter mon enfant
en six mois le fait que j'avais mon
peuple j'ai hébergé tu veux pas pleurer
on est tous ces problèmes non mais non
il ya plus grave les
bergers
tous les bons exemples
mais non non non mais ce n'est pas une
raison peu c'est très triste alors est
ce une raison pour dessert quelqu'un
parce que j'ai
sur les femmes que j'ai toujours un
terrible logique de l'intérim pas parce
que c'est décidé c'est pas facile à
manger que je disais le contraire ma
raison combien de juillan non mais c'est
fait mais je préfère m me dit alors je
te connais pas bien raison mais on tarde
boîte de nuit mais bien ça 25 ans à 30
ans beau d'unix comme tout le monde
tender de votre cas qu'est ce que tu
veux tu ta les bonnes
mathieu choix répond mathieu charette au
fer rouge avec deux potes on est au feu
rouge elle même qui traverse je vais
dire à mon pote ohlala le missile
regarde l'avion leur hâte de regarder la
barre regarde la tsr est bonne et c'est
cette voie la verdure malade je vous dis
pas la nana oui je le dis à mon peuple
et je sais ce qu'est en train de vivre
surtout run en train de vivre un
tournant catastrophique ce sont deux
personnes parce que lui aussi la menthe
il m'a dit tout à l'heure qu'il y aurait
des filets il fait du frais de personnel
sur des filtres cdu et qui maintenant
quand je pense que les dés la génération
la génération instagram menacé plus elle
va se jouer parce que ça met ça dans les
cours d'école mais c'est sûr
mais arrête tout est à démagogie
quand vous entendez tout ce que vous
avez entendu que ce que vous avez à dire
ce soir mathieu mais déjà je vous
saveurs à sortir ensemble bah oui
j'ai pu
moi j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup
la trouve plus belle la que sur les
photos ah ouais moi je juge pas les gens
et des photos avec la ville avoue cette
célibataire oui répond sérotine
l'appauvrir à calais le passé il a fait
l'homme ouais voilà tu partie 1 et quid
et l'attaquant hongrois il a dit qu
hélène le calme toi quelle moto
labit toutes les vraies donc c'est votre
souhait parce que lui et ressemble à un
homme mais ça on n'est pas chez panama
oui c'est fou et tout quelle histoire
après avoir sonné vers
m6 ils sont malins quand même ce qu'ils
sont en train de foot un beau bordel
avec ces messieurs magnifique de
diffusion on a déjà
créé des bons s'ils savent
pas mais pour moi le premier s'est pas
tué instagram en fait on est dans une
société qui est sensé de féministes ou
les femmes ont le pouvoir et instagram
c'est le truc le plus macho du monde ou
en fait les meufs et sont réduits à une
paire de seins à défiler toutes les
filles qui l'avaient ils sont quatre ans
toutes les fins fonds de mettre des
finances est en fait qu on a démêlé
éclaté au sol qui me sens très fier
oui
qui dit ça que tu connais pas l'eau près
le prénom d'une somme de tes petites
copines et de croissance
mais aussi en bout de votre vie et oui
mais guillaume chez n'importe quoi c'est
pas les hommes sont pas comme ça ddd
êtres pervers qui serait sur instagram
ou je sais pas quoi faire arrêter dit ok
c'est pas la faute c'est pas la faute
des réseaux arrêté il ya des hommes qui
déconne ya des hommes qui sont très bien
et à lille a donc signalé géraldine mais
taisez vous un peu le conseil à conclure
6-1 mais toi aussi tu es toi tu fais toi
parce que c'est
la scène française se mérite tout a cédé
boulimat à ces prix a été arrêté ni n'a
jamais l'air soyez romantique pour une
fois l'envoi d'un missile
vous déjà un petit mot gentil après j'ai
fait rentrer quelqu'un
passez will smith sétois remo cette
voie est-ce que vous avez un petit mot
gentil à vous dire tu as alors des noms
mais des leaders après je m'excuse avec
ce monsieur tout le monde est à voir
d'être feront pas franc mais je veux
être clash je m'excuse ans avec toutes
les femmes n'importe quoi les gens que
j'ai vexé voilà mais après j'ai dit ce
que je pensais après voilà donc ces
morts de quoi ces morts avec elle oui au
beau
tellement proches ouvert la porte à tous
les couples en doute à tous et où dadida
moi j'ai rien à lui dire j'étais déjà
vous avez plus avoir de relations
amicales du tout en fait terminé bah oui
moi je suis comme ça et tourner la page
et je jette le livre vous jeter l'île en
ouvrait un autre raymond lui
servir à quoi là c'est vrai et danila ce
que vous voulez peut-être mais j'ai pas
mon nom mais déjà nous lier d'amitié
avec raymond et peut-être on sait jamais
quand son téléphone et je devrais m'en
instagram est comme ça leaké mes photos
fier